alguna vez habéis pensado si el
aprendizaje es un medio para un fin o si
es un fin en sí mismo
si habéis pensado la primera os habéis
planteado alguna vez por cuántos
trabajos vais a pasar el resto de
vuestra vida
pues fijaos lo primero gracias por estar
aquí y es que todos compartimos un
momento de máxima curiosidad en nuestras
vidas y es cuando decidimos a qué nos
vamos a dedicar salimos todos en masa de
la universidad o de la academia elegimos
un camino profesional y seguramente
muchos nos hipotecamos de por vida al
mismo trabajo
y la cuestión es que olvidamos la
curiosidad entre las paredes de la
universidad y optamos por el confort de
tener el mismo trabajo durante toda la
vida
hoy quiero hablar de tres cosas una es
porque el aprendizaje es nuestro
principal superpoder la segunda es
porque perdemos esa motivación por
aprender y como no la tercera porque lo
que podemos hacer para seguir
aprendiendo durante toda la vida y
convertirnos en estudiantes para siempre
fijaos la mayoría de caminos
profesionales de todos nosotros tienen
tres cosas en común o tres patrones la
primera de ellas es que elegimos
estudiar una serie de conocimientos o
habilidades en una institución
tradicional la segunda es que optamos
por una empresa acorde a nuestro perfil
y la tercera es que si desarrollamos esa
serie de conocimientos y habilidades
dentro de la misma empresa
y bueno quizás cambiemos dos o tres
veces de trabajo quien sabe algunos
tenemos amigos que cambian cada menos de
un año pero bueno
la cuestión es que las cosas ahora están
cambiando bastante y para muchas
empresas los empleados ahora temen
perder sus competencias hay muchos
muchos países que ofrecen trabajadores
que realizan las mismas tareas por mucho
menos dinero y estamos viendo que la
tecnología y la intención oficial no
para de avanzar y que muy posiblemente
acaben desarrollando las tareas que a
nosotros nos han enseñado en la
universidad
bueno ahora mismo hay de dos realidades
una donde muchas personas deciden que su
nivel de su educación y su aprendizaje
termina una vez salen de la universidad
y hay otro grupo de personas que son -
que abrazan la curiosidad persiguen sus
talentos y siguen sus pasiones a lo
largo de su vida y si es una realidad
que no podemos ni siquiera dudar ninguno
de nosotros que el aprendizaje se ha
convertido en el activo más valioso que
tenemos hoy en día la cuestión es porque
no somos estudiantes de por vida o dicho
otra forma que podemos hacer para seguir
aprendiendo siempre hasta que nos
muramos y que el proceso se haga
pues hay que empezar por el principio
cuando llegamos como seres humanos a
este mundo tenemos todo por aprender y
mientras hay especies de animales que a
los pocos segundos en minutos ya están
caminando nosotros en realidad somos
dependientes y estamos bastante
limitados pero esto en realidad tiene
una gran ventaja y es que tenemos la
oportunidad de aprender bastante y si
miramos la evolución de todos los
factores que han contribuido a potenciar
nuestro aprendizaje el más llamativo
seguramente sea el lenguaje
durante millones de años nuestra especie
ha utilizado la comunicación verbal con
muchas otras especies en realidad pero
desde una ventana de tiempo bastante más
pequeña y cercana a nuestros días hemos
desarrollado seguramente la comunicación
más compleja de todo el planeta tierra
gracias a nuestro pensamiento abstracto
y simbólico
y la cuestión de esto es que hemos
intercambiado el poder de nuestra
genética por el poder del aprendizaje
antes ahora perdón somos capaces de
transferir nuestros pensamientos a otras
personas y generaciones tras
generaciones somos capaces de que el
conocimiento vaya quedando en nuestra
especie en forma de herramientas de caza
plantas medicinales vías y rutas de
viajes que ya tenían nuestros ancestros
y es que el aprendizaje no para y moldea
constantemente el cerebro y tras
millones de años de evolución biológica
la evolución cultural lo ha cambiado
todo y entre esas cosas nuestro cerebro
como veis el cerebro de nuestra especie
seguramente sea el que más se cambia a
sí mismo con cada experiencia y con cada
interacción del entorno no para de
aprender y seguramente en los primeros
años de vida el la tarea más compleja
cognitivamente a la que nos enfrentamos
sea el lenguaje como estamos viendo
en la cuestión es que ese lenguaje es el
que lo cambia todo
y lo hace de dos maneras dejando una
huella cognitiva en nuestra inteligencia
y en lo que llamamos reserva cognitiva
la inteligencia es un concepto difícil
de medir y categorizar pero seguramente
podríamos medirlo de dos maneras lo que
es la inteligencia fluida y la
cristalizada la inteligencia fluida
tiene un componente genético que debemos
aprovechar en los primeros años de vida
y de hecho los niños que son bilingües
tiene una capacidad atención mucho mayor
que el resto de niños seguramente porque
son capaces de elegir una estructura
gramatical y vocabulario en diferentes
contextos y lenguajes ahora ya estoy
viendo a todo el mundo haciendo a sus
niños bilingües desde pequeños y la
segunda la inteligencia cristalizada es
donde reside la neurociencia de la
sabiduría esta inteligencia sigue
avanzando con la edad mientras que la
inteligencia fluida disminuye es decir
nuestro cerebro nos hace más
inteligentes a lo largo del tiempo
aunque seamos muchos más aunque
envejecemos nos convertimos más
inteligentes más sabios y la segunda de
las maneras de huella neuronal que
dejamos mientras aprendemos es lo que
llamamos reserva cognitiva
en un estudio en monjas se vio que
algunas a pesar de padecer en su muerte
un alzhéimer bastante avanzado no tenían
síntomas antes de morir y esto porque
era cuando intentaron entender los
factores que contribuyeron a este
fenómeno encontraron que aquellas que en
sus cartas pondrán jóvenes tenían
estructuras gramaticales y un
vocabulario más rico eran las que
después a pesar de tener una demencia
avanzada no presentaban ningún síntoma y
es que esto es porque las monjas son
seres superiores al resto de personas o
es que en realidad su aprendizaje ha ido
reforzando sus conexiones neuronales la
realidad es que la evolución se ha
encargado de proteger a los cerebros más
valiosos que son aquellos que más
aprenden y la cuestión es por qué no
aprovechamos estas ventajas que nos da
el aprendizaje yo únicamente creo que es
por una razón y es que confundimos la
educación con el aprendizaje por
educación entendemos un modelo impuesto
por el estado con un temario fijo
salimos todos de la educación secundaria
elegimos uno
estudios universitarios y nos
hipotecamos de por vida y entendemos que
el aprendizaje en un modelo
industrializado de la educación no es
más que un fin no no es más que un medio
para un fin que es conseguir un título
universitario
y si lo pensáis de educación nación de
esta manera
en la revolución industrial muchas
personas que estaban en el campo pasaron
a las fábricas y las personas que
dirigían estas fábricas se daban cuenta
que aquellos con un menor nivel
educativo eran muy poco productivos
ante esta situación tuvieron una idea y
si creamos un sistema que les enseñe los
conocimientos y labores que van a
realizar durante toda su vida y así
nació la educación exactamente como una
fábrica donde los niños no son más que
piezas y materia prima los profesores no
son más que máquinas incrustan
conocimientos en las cabezas de los
demás y donde la escuela es la fábrica
cuyo este es de calidad son los exámenes
y donde las piezas defectuosas son
apartadas
en la actualidad esas fábricas ahora
mismo son grandes y edificios de
cristaleras en distritos financieros
donde sus operarios no trabajan con
manos sino con sus mentes
y todo esto tiene un lado oscuro y es
que la hiperespecialización a la que nos
vemos sometidos destruye por completo
nuestra creatividad nuestra visión y
nuestra capacidad de tomar decisiones
mientras antes nuestros ancestros
necesitaban el aprendizaje para tener
múltiples habilidades y desarrollarse
ahora la sociedad solo quiere que
tengamos una especialización en un campo
muy estrecho y esto destruye nuestra
motivación cuando el aprendizaje se
impone desaparece la motivación un
cerebro que nació preconfigurado para
aprender durante toda la vida e
interactuar con el medio de repente deja
de mostrar interés ante tres diosas
áreas de práctica en materias que no le
interesan y yo creo que muchas personas
ante esta situación lo que buscan es más
educación y más formación
el problema de esto es que el objetivo
de aprender no es conseguir más títulos
e insignias el objetivo aprender es
aumentar tus miras para conseguir ser
más creativo más inteligente más feliz y
como no que nos vaya mejor
económicamente y porque pues espera es
la primera de las razones y los
beneficios de ser un aprendiz durante
toda la vida es que nos convertimos en
generalistas y a ser generalistas somos
capaces de adaptarnos a los mercados en
constante evolución personas por ejemplo
que trabajan en marketing y que ahora
pueden conocer cómo funciona la
programación personas que trabajan en
diseño que entienden de psicología o
empresarios que bueno la veía necesitar
entender un poco de todo y es que las
personas que más especializan en una
edad temprana ganan más dinero a priori
pero a la larga se estancan y los que
más ganan son los generalistas que
además son los que acaban resolviendo
todos los problemas de la sociedad al
exponerse a múltiples ámbitos de
conocimiento son capaces de extraer
ideas y conectar puntos aparentemente no
obvios son personas que si quieren
lanzar un libro una startup o innovar
son las que tienen la capacidad de
juntar todas las piezas para llegar a un
mismo punto
y la tercera es que al convertirnos en
aprendices durante toda la vida somos
capaces de encontrar muchas más
trayectorias profesionales si cambiarse
de trabajo a otra empresa para hacer lo
mismo es un error porque no conseguimos
habilidades adyacentes que hagan de
nuestra vida un camino mucho más
divertido realmente
ante esta situación lo que está pasando
es que muchas empresas
instituciones ofrecen formación pero es
la misma formación de toda la vida el
mismo modelo pedagógico con un
un conjunto de habilidades aprender lo
que yo quiero proponer es un modelo en
el que tú creas tu propia educación es
muy distinto y lo he resumido en cuatro
pasos
el primero es que elijas cuál es tu
objetivo de aprendizaje mientras en un
máster en la universidad se escribe en
piedra lo que tienes que hacer ahora es
esto el que puedes elegir uno o dos
puedes elegir aprender cosas desde el
punto de vista profesional o personal
eso no importa lo que importa es que tu
interés se mantenga vivo el segundo una
vez ya tienes tu objetivo es que
conozcas cuáles son tus límites cuánto
tiempo tienes presupuesto dinero y una
vez tengas elegido eso podrás empezar a
diseñar tu aprendizaje que es el tercer
paso una vez que conozcas tus objetivos
y sus limitaciones es cuando puedes
un libro curso aumento y empezar a
aprender aunque si yo recomiendo no
pasar demasiado tiempo en esta fase
porque el coste oportunidad de no
aprender es muy alto
cuando llevas un tiempo aprendiendo
tendréis que aprender también a cambiar
nuestras estrategias estamos
acostumbrados a que siempre sigamos las
mismas rutinas en la institución y en la
universidad pero ahora eres tú el que
puedes un diario y cada día
apuntar que te funciona y qué no
entonces el aprendizaje si lo pensáis es
la estrategia de supervivencia más
eficaz que conocemos si pierdes todo
puedes perder tu dinero tu familia tus
amigos pero no pierdes lo que has
aprendido aprendido ante esta situación
hay dos realidades una en la que
abrazamos la curiosidad y no dejamos de
aprender nunca y otra en la que nos
acostumbramos a lo que ya tenemos o
dicho otra manera avanzas hacia el
crecimiento o retrocedes hacia la
seguridad
y la realidad de todo esto es que
aprender durante toda la vida es la
mejor inversión que puedes hacer en ti
mismo y te va a reportar más dividendos
que cualquier otra inversión que quieras
hacer
no sé vosotros pero yo ante esta
situación del aprendizaje se ha
convertido en el mayor activo que
tenemos como seres humanos y viendo
todas las ventajas que obtenemos y ha
tomado mi decisión ahora aquí vais a
hacer vosotros
[Aplausos]